[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
park
[Musique]
depuis cette semaine je veux parler de
l'enjeu de l'appropriation et de
l'usurpation même de
l'instrumentalisation de la l'identité
et de
la personne autochtones dans les
mobilisations comprendrez jeu très
inspirés par ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement tout le convoi des
camionneurs qui sont venus à taiwan mais
c'est pas la seule instance dans
laquelle j'ai vu c'est problématique là
je tiens à vous le dire mais c'est
l'exemple la plus récente donc je vais
me baser sur ce que j'ai vu à ce moment
là ce qui est problématique
donc ce sera pas sur les enjeux qui sont
défendues par le convoi mais vraiment
par l'utilisation des personnes et d
identité autochtone pour une
mobilisation qui ont inspiré ma
chronique je tiens à vous le dire
premièrement
première chose des autochtones qui se
mobilisent dans convoi y en a ils sont
présentes ce sont des personnes
autochtones il faut pas vraiment dire
que toutes les autres sont peu présentes
mais il ya des personnes autochtones
sont présentes pourquoi parce qu on est
comme tous les canadiens et québécois au
nord d opinion on a des visions qui sont
très différentes les unes des autres et
on va les défendre de façon différente
il ya une confusion par rapport aux
fêtes mobilisation tonnes c'est souvent
un grand bloc monolithique parce qu'il
parle pas aux séquences mobilise on le
fait en communauté en grand groupe a
énormément c'est un des exemples que
j'aime le plus utilisé on était tous
différents au niveau politique il y en a
qui viennent de la pnq elle de l'apn il
y en a qui venait des mobilisations
citoyennes y en a qui venait des groupes
des organismes urbain en communauté
c'était très variés et en plus on peut
compter l'appui des personnes qui se
mobiliser avec nous pour des enjeux de
justice sociale donc vous pouvez
imaginer la quantité d'opinion qui
existait dans le sein d'une
manifestation
cependant le message commun qui était
celle de faire entendre la voix des
communautés autochtones et elle était
vraiment porteuse et elle le fait que
tout le monde s'est mobilisé en même
temps le problème avec ça c'est que
beaucoup de gens qui ignoraient encore
beaucoup sur les enjeux autochtones je
dors c'était avant la commission
vérité-réconciliation donc même sur les
pensionnats il ya une confusion énorme
sur les droits taxes tonnes sur la
mobilisation tonnes sur le fait qu'on
chantait condensé qu'on faisait des
drames dans la rue pour se faire
entendre c'était pour utiliser une
manière de mobilisation qui avait été
interdite aux communautés autochtones
c'est à dire de droit de chanter de
danser nos propres champs et donc en les
utilisant c'était de dire on est encore
là on se fait encore entendre vous nous
avez pas eu c'était une symbolique qui
allait à l'encontre du droit canadien de
l'époque de nous empêcher d'être
culturellement autochtone et ça va mener
la discussion autour des passionnantes à
la discussion autour de l'arop les
années 60 le terrain le problème dans la
mobilisation je viens de voir c'est que
cette méthodologie le conclave est de
chanter de danser de dramé a été usurpée
utilisé lui-même instrumentalisés par
des groupes on a vu des groupes qui
chantait en criant yabba dabba doo yabba
dabba doo et donc de les baptiser la
nation il ya pas de doute parce que
personne champ de m il utilisait des
tambours traditionnels de façon
inadéquate c'était très insultant parce
que ça ramené à l'idée que quand on
chante et on danse on dit n'importe quoi
alors que c'est pas vrai
l'utilisation des chants des danses a
ramené à une fierté à un sentiment de
bonheur donc en utilisant son on voulait
recréer des moments autochtone qui ont
existé qui ont été très puissant à
l'international mais là que ça a fait
près de pau est parce que justement
beaucoup de monde et comme notons sinon
peut vous faire ça c'est pas c'est pas
comme ça qu'on chante pas comme ça qu'on
danse et d'avoir beaucoup de gens mais
nommée hilton c'est qu'un vrai qu'ils
sont autochtone et de découvrir avec les
médias sociaux qui venait de l'intérieur
que beaucoup de ces groupes autochtones
leur était autoproclamé
cette 10è de telle ou telle nation alors
que c'est nationale n'existe pas au sein
des autres nations qui se reconnaissent
les unes envers les autres pour avoir eu
des relations pendant des centaines
d'années des milliers d'années voire
l'on approche des problématiques de
l'appropriation culturelle de
l'instrumentalisation de l'identité du
corps autochtone aussi qui portant de
droit faut vous rendre compte que les
corps physique autochtones sont porteurs
de droits parce que si on veut on se
base sur la loi sur les indiens le quota
sanguins et calcul est donc le corps
autochtone porte des droits selon son
corps et dans les dernières et dans les
derniers mois on a vu beaucoup dans une
nouvelle justement les questions de
l'appropriation mais aussi d'auto
identification de l'identité autochtone
donc d'aller déterrer les ossements des
ancêtres il ya très très longtemps pour
dire qu'ils étaient autochtone par le
parti d'une m'excuser à des gens qui se
mobilisent autour de devenir demandé
comment je vais demander des comptes à
des gens qui s'auto identifié comme
autochtone parce que pour moi l'auto
identification c'était un peu aller à
l'encontre de loi sur les indiens c'est
correct mais c'est parce que j'avais une
vision qui avait un grand angle mort
c'est à dire je peux même pas imaginer
qu'on plus utilisé l'identité autochtone
pour quelque chose qui donnerait des
avantages faut voir que pour nous
c'était un désavantage d'être autochtone
quand on était plus jeunes donc moi
c'est ça se peut pas mais avec la
réconciliation avec le travail qui est
fait par nos alliés allochtone on voit
que des gens qui sans que les avantages
qui sont des emplois qui sont des
bourses qui sans ddd droit
de briller sur les autochtones
puisqu'ils connaissent bien le système
ils peuvent naviguer à travers les
embûches mieux que vous n'importe qui
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut naviguer
à travers des embûches dans une
manifestation en ce sens les droits
autochtones comme les web souhaitant par
exemple tu fait résonner le fait de
déplacer une femme autochtone d'un site
qu'elle habite c'est de çà va à
l'encontre du droit international donc
le canada était déplacé illégalement des
personnes autochtones de sur leur site
pour pouvoir défendre des groupes d d d
des industries parce que ce faire
plusieurs autres endroits
donc d'utiliser cette identité là pour
pouvoir ensuite faire une mobilisation
faire respecter des droits autochtones
qui sont pas portés par cette personne
là parce que son identité
ça peut être nous identifie une
reconnexion récente mais c'est pas
important d'endroits collectif la même
manière que quand on utilise sur des
dans des situations de mobilisation
autochtone ça devient quelque chose qui
est confus aucun d'eux parce que cette
découvert depuis pas très longtemps mais
à ottawa par exemple on a vu des
personnes des organisateurs qui par le
passé ont fait des publications sur
leurs médias sociaux à eux je tiens à
dire que les médias sociaux j'utilisais
c'est les médias sociaux des personnes
mobilisées sur la place sur place dans
ces négociations utilisaient des mots
très très très dérogatoire pour parler
de communauté autochtone de la culture
autochtone et rendent sur place surtout
identifié autochtone reçoit une pipe
une pub sacré devient tout d'un coup un
tracteur avec une nation qui est créé
pour le moment
c'est que il ya une mouvance qui
existent aussi au sein même des
personnes qui
croient aux mouvements de suprématie
blanche de dire qu'ils sont autochtones
au canada de dire qu'ils ont des droits
parce qu'ils sont des premiers peuples
même une théorie comme quoi il aurait
traversé l'atlantique et donc le premier
autochtone qui ont habité le continent
américain se serait nord-américain
excusez moi ça serait des européens et
toutes ces théories leurs ressorts
pendant la mobilisation on le voit et
c'est en utilisant
l'identité autochtone con qu'on veut
faire avancer sa cause avec avec sol et
d'avoir même des personnes qui sont des
alliés du passé nous dire bella vous
êtes présent vous devriez vous suivre
l'avez-vous
de se rendre compte que certains de ces
alliances certains utilisent et puis le
sont conditionnels ce sans
conditions varient
depuis et même d'un visibilisation si le
message que les communautés autochtones
porte ne leur plaisent plus c'est à dire
de se faire entendre de pas être
contents de leur désaccord avec ce qui
ce qui est présenté est on vu avec par
exemple
[Musique]
l'organisme qui a imprimé les drapeaux
qui était utilisé sur les camions nous
n'appuyons pas du tout les
revendications dans cette manifestation
le camp tipi construit sur un site à le
voc est là les deux communautés
algonquines non vous le faites en fait
une occupation de notre territoire vous
n'êtes pas le bienvenu parce que
ils ont
parlé avec la nation présente sur ce
site et donc c'était de manoeuvrer à
travers les droits canadiens détroit
autochtone pour pouvoir essayer de faire
entendre sa mobilisation en background
se rend compte que le moment donné ça
devient
un bric à brac de plein d'idées et
communautés autochtones disent non à
arrêter pourquoi vous parler pour moi je
vais me représenter pop eux se font
demander d'arrêter de
de défendre le droit de vote aux
garanties autochtone quand tu es
vraiment autochtone on est on devient
même un problématique donc ses amitiés
le très légère s'écroule après parce que
justement la parole autochtone qui était
pratiqué un moment donné ne l'est plus à
ce moment là beaucoup d'enjeu fait que
vous comprendrez ce sera pas la seule
fois sera pas la dernière fois que vous
allez entendre parler d'appropriation
identitaire d'usurpation d'identité
d'instrumentalisation autochtones aussi
parce qu'on parle de garant va mettre un
autochtone au devant de la philo faire
parler quelqu'un puis les autochtones
sont tous présents c'est pas vrai au
regard des embouts support vous voulez
se parler c'est pas vrai parce que on
voit après qu'est ce qui se passe et ce
qui se passe dans au sein de la
mobilisation ne représente pas du tout
les valeurs de groupe que les
communautés d'accueil donc c'est de dire
nous associer à sa voulu nous associer à
vos comportements c'est non donc c'est
le droit aussi de se retirer d'une
manifestation quand on est en danger
c'est le droit de se retirer de
manifestations par le message change est
présentement baisse est de se rendre
compte aussi quand nos voix sont
utilisés
dans des manifestations alors fait est
chaude
message compliqué à faire entendre parce
que c'est tellement vaste mais en
espérant que cela vous intéresse que le
sujet justement de l'identification
autochtone va être très présente en 2022
on va voir plusieurs des raisons
pourquoi être autochtone c'est payant et
que ses défauts les gens se défendre
d'ailleurs en disant aux autochtones
d'arrêter de nous dire qu'on est
autochtone ou post coloniale comme
action mais ensuite des gens vont aller
en cour de justice pour demander à
l'état colonial de l'ordi à eux qui sont
autochtones et de renvoyer le certificat
d'identification vous comprendrez que ça
va être très problématique très chaud
ferait aussi émotionnel parce que des
gens qui ont été déconnectés de leur
famille de façon forcée vont être
ramassées dans le lot de ceux qui se
reconnecte pour des raisons x il ya
examen alors gardez l'oeil ouvert et
vérifier vraiment quand une mobilisation
autochtone est présente que cette
mobilisation là est juste et qu'elle est
vraiment représentative des communautés
autochtones et surtout passé une belle
semaine n'hésitez pas à partager les
vidéos et surtout hésitez pas à nous
envoyer vos questions on adore pouvoir y
répondre